[Musik]
die schulzeit für die meisten kinder
eine unbeschwerte zeit
das jedenfalls wünschen sich alle eltern
prägend ist sie auf jeden fall im märz
2013 wird diese idylle jäh zerstört
durch eine mitteilung der kantonspolizei
bern schweiz aktuell berichtet herr
mutter hat sich im januar 2012 mit der
kantonspolizei begnadet hier sind sehr
offen vor sexueller übergriff wurde im
fokus von der umfangreiche ermittlungen
ein 43-jähriger schulsozialarbeiter habe
sich die marge im song dem konto als
schulsozialarbeiter 30 sie sieht als
kanton baselland bein und sommer tun mit
muskat also der großteils in der
späteren opfer im rahmen der tätigkeit
keiner glenton suche nach einem privaten
kontakt und rollt und der größte teil
der opfer stammte konnte die polizei hat
20 opfer ausfindig gemacht die ersten
übergriffe geschahen bereits 1996
der mutmaßliche täter ist ein vorzeige
pädagoge gefeiert als einer der ersten
schulsozialarbeiter der deutschen
schweiz eine schule in der region bern
ist besonders betroffen
sehr schöne tag das darf nicht wahr sein
das ist der erste gedanke sie und die
zweite ist wenn man die vergangenheit
wie viel das tageslicht haben soll bei
dem nicht ablesen was sie nie gesät
tisch und insofern - schockiert
niemand hätte es gedacht oftmals nahm
der schulsozialarbeiter die kinder sogar
in der freizeit mit in einer alphütte im
berner oberland
was hier geschah weiß niemand
mittlerweile hat der beschuldigte b21
sexuelle übergriffe an kindern gestanden
der prozess wird wohl erst 2014
stattfinden
bis zu einer verurteilung gilt die
unschuldsvermutung
wie kann es sein dass jemand der in
institutionen mit kindern arbeitet über
jahre knaben sexuell missbraucht und
niemand etwas merkt sind unsere gesetze
ungenügend oder sind wir zu wenig 18
eine spurensuche in einem bereich voller
tabus
[Musik]
ich kannte den beschuldigten
schulsozialarbeiter b schon bevor alles
ans licht kam
bei meinen recherchen für einen
dokumentarfilm über hyperaktive kinder
stieß ich auf die deutsche sinnstiftung
sie vermittelte mir b als ihren
schweizer vertreter die sind stiftung
ist bekannt dafür dass die lebhafte
jungs nicht mit medikamenten therapiert
sondern ihnen mit ferienwochen auf der
alb auslauf und bewegung verschafft wir
filmten b im sommer 2011
er arbeitete als coach mit solchen jungs
und setzte sich im film sympathisch und
kompetent für die anliegen der kinder
und gegen den zunehmenden leistungsdruck
in unserer gesellschaft ein
hier verantwortet musik dass wir
möglichst geld verdient sind
verantwortlich muss sie sich um die
kinder zu kümmern
heute erscheinen bis aussagen in einem
anderen licht aber damals fiel auch ich
auf ihn herein
b drohen nun zwischen siebeneinhalb und
15 jahren haft ich bin erleichtert
gehört der junge den er in meinem dok
film betreute nicht auch noch zu seinen
opfern
nach der ausstrahlung des filmes ende
2011 erhielt ich ein irritierendes mail
ein vater schrieb b habe vor jahren als
kirchen sozialarbeiter seinen sohn
sexuell missbraucht b hatte 1999 unseren
sohn an einem weekend im jura sexuell
missbraucht
ich konnte den film nicht zu ende
schauen wut und trauer stiegen in mir
hoch nehmen sie mit mir kontakt auf b
wechselt er auch häufig seinen
arbeitsort um die spuren zu verwischen
ich ging der sache nach und hatte keinen
anlass an den aussagen des vaters zu
zweifeln zudem fand ich heraus dass
inzwischen auch die polizei ermittelte
und b verhaftet hatte der vorfall den
der vater schilderte ereignete sich 1999
in der region basel land b hatte als
kirchen sozialarbeiter dort eine
konfirmanden klasse betreut zum
missbrauch sei es gekommen als er den
jungen nach der konfirmation auf ein
wochenende in den jura eingeladen hatte
schrieb der vater
öffentlich auftreten will er aber nicht
aus rücksicht auf seinen sohn
diese hat nun seit die polizeilichen
ermittlungen laufen erstmals ausgesagt
diese geschichte zeigt auf wo die
probleme bei sexuellem missbrauch liegen
und warum leute wie b so lange
unentdeckt bleiben können bei der opfer
beratungsstelle castagna hört man fast
täglich missbrauchs geschichten
die erfahrung zeigt sexueller missbrauch
an kindern ist in den allermeisten
fällen ein beziehungsdelikt wird über
nun sofort sämtliche person noch einmal
dosen sozialere soziale umfeld vom rind
das heißt es besteht bezirken aber wo
sich in der familie ihnen schließt als
früher als die oder so in der stadt
relativ lange zeit zum center für
gegenzug entwicklung der bezirk und die
abhängigkeit so dass es dann wenn man
ein anfangs mit übergriff kkw meter
bringen
für den jungen konfirmanden aus der
region basel land war ein enger
vertrauter gewesen mit seinem vater
konnte er bis heute nicht darüber reden
was damals geschah
nur einer kirchen mitarbeiterin hatte er
sich in seiner not anvertraut
diese erzählt es dann dem vater
[Musik]
in der regel ist es so dass es sind die
täglich person schützt will sie aber
lebendig hat die täglich person und will
handelt will über diese schon bereich
vor sich selber retten
und dass man so eigentlich gar nicht
sofort sich sehr sagte das klingt dann
doch recht und meistens erst dann wenn
es sind immer nur haltet also war
einfach der druck so massiv steigt das
meine kreditkarten im vita und dann war
traut sie sich irgendwie der vater war
in einer schwierigen situation
er war verunsichert und hatte nichts in
der hand der junge schwieg aber selbst
wenn er geredet hätte eine anzeige in
solchen fällen ist eine heikle
angelegenheit meisten zur situation
verursacht gossau und user fach hin sind
teil wie sehr ungenau oder sie wechselt
und möchte ich da nicht sicher
und das hat natürlich auch ganz
verheerende konsequenzen für die person
wo dann beschuldigt wird das führt dann
meistens zur freistellung im job
verliert dann vielleicht auch
persönliche beziehungen also sicher bis
wo ganz schwerwiegend ist und darum
überlegt sich viele lüth zweimal ob sie
das wirklich wand in gang setzte und zum
anderen ist es also dass im
strafverfahren dann schwere belastung
genug screen zu kommen
das geht dann zügen übernahme womit ganz
speziell organisiert werden
und schließlich haben sich aus organo in
verdacht bringen dass man über fall
schuldig dass man sogar es ihnen eher
verletzt
und das führt dann insgesamt zu einer
konstellation berufen abzeichnen
verzichtet im fall b ermittelt die
kantonspolizei des berner oberlandes nun
seit eineinhalb jahren zum fall selbst
darf man nicht sagen da das verfahren
noch läuft
gabi berger ist chefin der spezial
fahndung 1 sie ist sich sehr wohl
bewusst dass bei sexuellen delikten
gegen kinder ganz schwierige situationen
entstehen
das versucht die polizei speziell zu
berücksichtigen das hat sich sehr stark
für andere der letzten 15 jahre der mix
arbeit im zimmer mit sexuellem
missbrauch und sexualdelikt 2002 es sind
verschiedene bestimmungen im oberhofer
gesetz in kraft treten
wo bestehen mit dass speziell
ausgebildete polizistinnen und
polizisten sind befragen das befragung
von gleichen geschlecht sollte gemacht
werden dass man speziell geschulter
stream lichkeit als gerecht ausgestaltet
sind
das sind die beiden profis wenn es um
solche fälle geht könig und theres
widmer sind für die ermittlungen bei
sexualdelikten gegen kinder zuständig er
befragt die knaben sie die mädchen
in diesen räumen finden die befragungen
statt
ich sage eigentlich durch entwicklungen
wir probieren zwar regional peter und am
schluss die immer der wahrheit mit ihr
arbeitet er im kriechgang das tut er
beurteile war der wahrheit wie
verantwortung muss tragen dass es nicht
so schwierig unsere bürger aussage macht
ist es viel einfacher als bei fragen
oder einfach nur einsatz- und nach einer
fast fertig
bestimmte zellen was da passiert ist
schwierig
damit das gespräch wegen der mitschrift
des protokolls nicht unterbrochen werden
muss wird alles mit einer videokamera
aufgezeichnet und im zimmer nebenan
mitverfolgt muss könig erlebt oft dass
die kinder die täter in schutz nehmen
das nachher nie vernahm
wenn wir mit dem schönen dreht wie es
für die xii
das ist meistens ja es ist nicht so
schlimm sie wenig argument das ist noch
ganz gut gegangen bemerkt aber da blieb
nur bis das werk bisherigen getragen
wenn man nachfragt merkt dass der
trainer diese gedanken macht das
aufgrund von sich aus sagt sagt britz
gefängnis muss ist das leider bis wo wir
wahnsinnig berührt wenn man anmerkt dass
sie schon früh dem kind wenn es woanders
aber sicher nicht nur ungerechtfertigten
beschuldigungen von kindern gebe es sehr
selten sagt könig die täter hingegen
hätten allgemein weit weniger skrupel
und verfolgten auf dieselbe strategie
das musste wohl gedanken wo man immer
wieder gerät ist das geschafft
erster linie die vorwürfe abstreitet
bloomstein der sogar quasi in den opfern
in erbringt ist das eine sache die sie
vom centro gehört ein kind das nur gut
tun als unbedingt wo der herr roboter
robbe hat mitgemacht dass sie so grund
musste wo man immer wieder geht aber ufo
durch aktives jahres problem mit dem ich
komme nicht schlagen bsv froh dass er
das thema torhüter dass sie das hilfen
bekommt
zurück zum fall des sexuellen
missbrauchs in der region basel land
1999 kommt es hier nicht so eine anzeige
es fehlen die beweise der betroffene
junge redet nicht und sozialarbeiter b
von der kirchgemeinde auf den verdacht
angesprochen streitet alles ab
er kündigt bald darauf und zieht weiter
das auftauchen wenn durch den stand dass
die ihre sachen zusammen park hat und
ihn in anderen kantonen genf wo sie denn
so quasi von neuem wieder v und wenn
dort entstand die möglichkeit dass man
wieder bekannte anwachsen so auch b er
lässt sich 2001 im kanton bern anstellen
dort machte eine erstaunliche karriere
in einer schule in köniz wird er als
einer der ersten schulsozialarbeiter der
deutschschweiz gefeiert er ist allseits
beliebt und bekommt sogar eine eigene
kolumne in einer zeitung
[Musik]
in köniz sind ganz viele schüler froh um
ihn
er versteht ihre probleme ist locker und
umgänglich in kürzester zeit hat er sich
etabliert
er hat gut sachen los schon mit ihm wird
ganzen ordner mit person sie und
sympathisch und mit dem geld
aber der hervorragender pädagoge hat
zwei gesichter
seine dunkle seite kenne nur die kinder
die es am eigenen leib erfahren das ist
stringent die linie und nicht 20
und dann nimmt man sie überhaupt
aushalten am 6
ich habe glaube ich leider oftmals
alaska und nicht ein hervorragender
pädagoge erika haltiner leitet die
fachstelle limiter diese entwickelt
präventionskonzepte für schulen und
behörden im umgang mit sexueller gewalt
sie weiß zwar dass sich sexualstraftäter
oft solche berufe aussuchen und besser
an die kinder heranzukommen
trotzdem warnt sie davor pädophile
generell zu kriminalisieren pädophilie
als solches ist strafbar zwischen
verlagen und ich glaube dass mir
pädophil veranlagte nicht früher
verurteilen will wenn wir das machen den
entschwinden und entzieht man ihnen
sicherheit quasi im therapeutischen
[Musik]
kontext langer und wenn man das nicht
nach wenn sie mit der brd nichts risiko
sehr hoch dass sexualstraftaten begangen
werden
b hatte diese grenze allerdings bereits
überschritten davon ist der betroffene
vater aus dem kanton basel landschaft
überzeugt
[Musik]
sein sohn hat 20 kilo zugenommen und die
sache lässt ihm keine ruhe
er findet heraus dass b in köniz
arbeitet und informiert eine bekannte
die dort unterrichtet 2002 hätte es
gerücht breit gemacht
kraft wo das den handel zuständige
schule etikett mitteilt dass am früheren
arbeitsort sowie sexueller übergriff
basiert sie und das gerücht themenheft
no und dem 7er nachgegangen wie man
genau vorgehen soll ist 2002 nicht klar
die schulleitung kontaktiert das
schulamt dieses stützt sich auf die
leitlinien des berner lehrerverbandes
und rät zu einer konfrontation mit b
wird mit dem gespräch gesucht mehrheiten
konfrontiert mit der situation einfach
konstruiert zeigt kreis geständnis hätte
schlussendlich zeit ja ganz einfach
vorstellen dass umstände op de dam
gebiete weil das gerücht biscayne handy
und im smi
konfrontationen sind schwierig besser
wäre indizien sammeln und fachstellen
aufsuchen
die polizei rät jedenfalls von solchen
konfrontationen ab es hat verschiedene
jahr steigt er aus der täter
konfrontiere auf privater ebene das
warum der tat dennoch eine strafe feuer
in gang und hat der gleichheit k10 eu
sorge sich gut zu überlegen heizkörper
des materials vernichten
bei der konfrontation 2002 erreicht man
das b einwilligt dass man auf der
gemeindeverwaltung in baselland
nachfragen darf ohne einwilligung ist
nachfragen nämlich gesetzlich verboten
aber b verschweigt das pfarramt wo man
vom missbrauch gewusst hätte hier
müssten sich gesetzlich etwas ändern
es gab blumen das nicht quasi
vermeintliche täter quasi seiten woher
das man gruppe frage das ist eine klage
der sei natürlich nicht da gibt es
wurden geleistet gewährt man
informationen sondern das muss und da
sind wir seit er will informationen vor
dem töten und wenige krieg endspurt um
das g2 ist klar stellung
das bisherige system schützt die täter
denn auch das pfarramt hätte die
informationen nicht herausgeben dürfen
der pfarrer und der steht nämlich einer
schweigepflicht eine unbefriedigende
situation die man relativ einfach ändern
könnte wenn es um den schutz von kindern
geht
also aus meiner sicht wäre es das
geschieht steht wenn man wird im
strafgesetzbuch die möglichkeit von mal
die rechte szene auf
so stiege ganz gewöhnliche
arbeitsverhältnis nicht nur auf amts-
und berufsgeheimnisträger und damit
hätte die dann ein 8 fertigungs grund
wenn so verdacht aufkommt dass ich unter
einer nächste schule im informationen
weitergehe gebe es ein solches
melderecht hätte der pfarrer im
baselbiet auf anfrage die schule in bern
warnen können
das bedürfnis der öffentlichkeit die
kinder besser zu schützen ist groß es
erstaunt nicht dass nach bekanntwerden
des falles b sofort wieder sogenannte
schwarze listen gefordert werden bei den
lehrern oder im pflegebereich gibt es
sie schon
zum thema schwarze liste muss man gerade
mal klarstellen dass es geht immer darum
geht das opfer schon rechtskräftig
lehrbefugnis nummer hat oder dass eine
flagge bereich anonymer tätig darf sie
das heißt es muss irgendwo vom gericht
festgestellt wurde sie das bis begangen
hat gar keine jugendliche oder ein
anderes schweres strafbare handlung in
dem zwei mann kann man das auch aus
denen auch sozialarbeiter aber die
müsste da die gleiche regelung dass sie
also dann im strafe war als mitspieler
verurteilt worden sind war gestimmt
man ahnt es schon selbst wenn es
schwarze listen für sozialarbeiter geben
würde
dort wäre b nicht aufgetaucht immer noch
hatte niemand anzeige gemacht immer noch
lief kein verfahren gegen ihn
das ist der regelfall die dunkelziffer
bei diesen delikten ist extrem hoch
also grob statistische zahl jeder 100
stefan wird überhaupt auf deck das ist
schon mal relativ wenig zu dem fall
beauftragt werden
gerade mal circa sechs prozent zu einer
zeit und 46 prozent oder nah zeigt
werden werden gerade mal ungefähr 13
prozent verurteilt also mehr bewegen die
müssen in vorurteil inspirieren
nur ganz wenige fälle kommen also ans
licht
und auch in köniz kommt es 2002 wie es
meistens kommt der verdacht lässt sich
nicht erhärten
passiert ist ihr ehrgeiz irgendwo
fleisch am knochen und insofern
ist ja das ganz schwierig wenn man
politisch stellen sich vor
schlussendliches werden als einzige
vorwurf den man schauen ob er schuldig
ist oder unschuldig ist und das ist ganz
ganz so bisher nicht nur kinder auch
erwachsene haben angst jemanden in
verruf zu bringen
genau das nützen pädophile straftäter
oftmals aus
mitmachen darf nicht aufgrund von x
factor lag sondern voller annahm und
easy redlichkeit hinteren ist oft nur
aufgehoben wo name eigentlich tatsachen
schaffe ich glaube das ist so der
schmale grat wo täter schützt und wo sie
auch ihnen gewinnt wenn sie zum beispiel
sagen marinieren mit mir das machen denn
zeigen wir gefühl wenn sie genau in die
redlichkeit das ist manipulations mittel
für ihn unvorstellbar kite vor ihrer tat
die täter manipulieren nicht nur die
kinder sie manipulieren auch die
erwachsenen
und die kinder
[Musik]
sie gehen oft vergessen dabei
häufig war 0 2 gefahr besteht dass
tatsächlich das kind übergriff erlebt da
nicht doch das eigentlich schon so viel
dass man muss handeln
als das kind schützen sie irgendwie gold
schulen haben die pflicht ihre kinder zu
schützen
deshalb macht man schulsozialarbeiter b
2002 in köniz immerhin die auflage dass
er nicht mehr allein mit den kindern
ausflüge machen dürfe erika hat ina ist
das aber zu wenig der dettling krimizeit
jahr semikontakt wohnungsbau während
ihrer arbeit in afrika privatisiert ich
glaube das ist mit einem von der auflage
politischen -standard in professionelle
und extremwetter geschafft wenn ihr kind
in der schule sozial aber kontakt haben
denn ist beschränkt sich daher genau auf
der ruhm und auf der kontext und die
kontaktpflege privat noch immer ein
anderer name zu den hinter das sind
genau die situationen ausgesetzt werden
wer hingegen baut die privaten kontakte
aus
2005 mietet er im berner oberland eine
alphütte und nimmt oft auch kinder mit
hierher
natürlich immer in absprache mit den
eltern alle mögen ihn ja gern
die unterschiedlichsten kinder
verbringen wochenenden hier
der benachbarte bauer war mit b
befreundet und hat sie alle gekannt
pokerface hilfspaket für möglich
die junge union erkennt bis zu acht
vereine zahlten das ja bis machen das
ist auch meine landwirtschaftsbetriebe
eigentlich noch schlauer ist ja hier
geholfen ad wandler gruppe machen oder
gemacht mit einem kind oder gar mancher
denkt dass das so ist das jetzt für ihn
als solche erkannt und also schaut das
wohnheim nachträglich gemacht dass
montag merkte was im berner oberland
genau geschah ist gegenstand der
ermittlungen die seit eineinhalb jahren
andauern
in deren verlauf bekam die polizei noch
einen anderen wichtigen hinweis
offenbar war auch in der pädophilen
szene im internet aktiv nach einigen
monaten mehrere von russland ischen
polizei oder fundbüro das im internet
aufnahme zirkulieren wo man beschuldigt
hofer kennt und gestützt auf die
historiker gemacht und seinen hang ich
werde auch die opferung von acht
missbrauchten kindern hat man also
bilder im internet gefunden was darauf
zu sehen ist gibt die polizei natürlich
nicht bekannt bei der
bundeskriminalpolizei in bern gehen
hinweise aus dem in und ausland ein
rund 1400 sind es pro jahr thomas
walther ist chef der fachstelle kobik
welche die internet kriminalität
bekämpft ihn erschüttert wie diese
delikte verharmlost werden also muss das
so vorstellen sie besitzt geht es liegt
wohl einfach die beauty aus dusche unser
lied o du fröhliche ja denn pedro
pornografische bilder aus dem alltag
vergessen dass das eigentlich crime
scene von einer firma ein missbrauch vor
man hat ja immer gehört dass sie einfach
möglich aber dass sie aber nicht einfach
bitte hier wird es ging weder missbrauch
die das blut wieder und retour
konsumieren und mich eigentlich vor ewig
team ist jede kommen wird verhindere
also dass ich zehnte die tür der eu
drastisch auf der anderen seite ist als
zu meiner zahlungsmittel worten dass man
immer wieder frisches blut oder muss
agierte dass man sein büro wieder neues
material über hunt und denn die leute
natürlich zum täter irgendwann zu einem
schlitten und werden sauber
daten und die sauber kinder missbrauchen
die szene hält sich zunehmend in
verschlüsselten netzwerken so genannten
dark rooms auf und es bräuchte viel mehr
leute die diese beobachten juristin
sandra mogli hat im rahmen ihrer
dissertation bei thomas walther
gearbeitet und so einen einblick in die
szene erhalten ohne verdeckte ermittlung
käme man pädophilen tätern kaum auf die
spur
da ist man sich einig aber was sandra
mogli täglich an strafbaren handlungen
zu sehen bekam überstieg oft das
erträgliche vorlegen jetzt auf ganz
klinischen babys zwischen videokanal man
sich jetzt einloggen und oftmals ist so
weil man sich ins forum sie locken
das mit deinen zerspringen damit noch
akzeptiert wird
ich spüre ich zum beispiel da macht eine
also magazin also wir müssen keine
trafford eine ganze garde häftlinge und
machte mit kinderpornografie und einer
post jetzt helfen die das gut und wenn
er richtig wenn er fürs nächste magazin
haben dass das in den eigenen tochter
praktisch schickt einen kontakt also zum
duschen aber oftmals werden ratschläge
sucht warum ich hoffe herr über also da
zum beispiel hat eine was mal gesucht
von ihnen gesagt seine in belgien
auch wenn es schwierig ist die identität
der täter im netz zu knacken der fall
zeigt dass es dank internationaler
zusammenarbeit doch immer wieder gelingt
trotzdem sandra magnus fazit ist
ernüchternd
es geht wirklich sg grenze fuhren die
täter fühle sich so sicher auf den
siebten
dass sie ganz oft treten einige über
ihre erfahrungen
ganz offen unterstützt die suche nach
opfern und alles also dass er mich mal
funktioniert das war wirklich über
illegale sachen weiß dass er die strafe
nach sich
also offen darüber diskutieren das ist
erschreckend und was das andere nicht
aus es nicht aufhört dass es mit ihm
wieder neu sie dazu es könnte also wo
sich die leute versammelt sandra mogli
will das bewusstsein in der
öffentlichkeit schärfen für diese neue
form von kriminalität
darum hält sie auch vorträge vor
jurastudenten pädosexuelle täter tummeln
sich nicht nur in verschlüsselten
darkrooms sie suchen sich ihre opfer
meist in ganz normalen netzwerken
sexuelle belästigung ist alltag wenn
kinder regelmäßig checken möglichkeit
das erschreckende stieg dann werden sie
sich speziell die channel sollte wofür
dank sind also gerade jetzt wo polyprint
abgehängt und eltern sind die kinder
ganz genau über die schulter und sie
nicht unbeaufsichtigt mit dem pc im
zimmer platz vertrieben
pädophile täter gehen sehr zielstrebig
zur sache wie dieser chart zeigt das
geht dann meistens so los also zuerst
kommt die begrüßung und diese effekte
sind danach meistens das einzige was
noch keinen sexuellen inhalt habt ja und
dann geht es mal so ein bisschen hier
los man stellt sich blöd was meinst du
redest du große brüste auch ganz wichtig
tonga sehr beliebt auch legen sie
übrigens männer aus der schon einmal
sexuelle erfahrung gehabt nein
man wird uns noch deutlicher und wird
vielleicht auch auszahlen iphone immer
sehr beliebt braucht geld
man könnte ziel ist es oft die kinder zu
treffen
aber selbst in den chats geht es dann
schnell um pornografie was im realen
leben mindestens als sexuelle
belästigung taxiert würde kann im netz
allerdings nur schwer geahndet werden
berichtet das kind selber anzeige
erstattet und wir ihnen einige nach
haben wir um kinder für die zuhälter aus
dass erstens erkannt als er bestraft und
zweitens 16 möglich auf der welt macht
zum erzeuger schaute bei peter sexuellen
übergriffen im internet ist es also
genau gleich wie bei sexuellen
übergriffen in der realität
man kann solche übergriffe nur
verhindern und kinder schützen wenn sie
jemand sieht und sehen will und bei der
bundeskriminalpolizei meldet blenden wir
zurück zum fall des schulsozialarbeiters
b
2008 kündigt er in köniz von sich aus
ohne dass weitere verdachtsmomente
aufgetaucht wären seine spur hätte sich
fast verloren wäre da nicht der
betroffene vater aus dem baselbiet
gewesen der immer noch ab und zu im
internet verfolgt was b macht als er
2010 herausfindet dass sich b in vier
schulhäusern im kanton solothurn als
sozialarbeiter anstellen lässt meldet er
sich dort per mail
bei der fachstelle perspektive welche b
für diese schulen angestellt hat nimmt
man den hinweis ernst wir sind der am
aldi nord dass es mir damals erst
versucht mit dem vater kommt auch durch
sind dass man die mal die auch
direktorin der vater des thematik so
bestätigt hat aber der krankheit wieder
einer saison werden machen und es
einfach informieren dass mir ein anruf
dies auch hin
auch hier wieder man lässt sich beraten
fragt in den solothurner schulen nach
überall hört man nur gutes über b direkt
auf die vorwürfe angesprochen gewährt
dieser sogar einsicht in die akten von
köniz wo ja alles schon mal
aufgearbeitet worden war
gerade weil karin stoppt die sache ernst
nimmt möchte sie das gerücht aber
endlich aus der welt schaffen wie sie
dem fahrer wurde dass der mitarbeiter
schön aber nach lage überfällig er
verletzt sich machen um ihren ihn
dahingehend beraten dass er die arbeiten
am alten zoll beauftrage mir genau
entsprechend kosten übernahm geleistet
und ärgern die arbeit in biel streit der
betroffener vater muss also plötzlich
selbst mit einer anzeige wegen
ehrverletzung rechnen
er hatte den verdacht doch sehr lange
immer wieder überall gestreut
ohne selbst zur polizei zu gehen
[Musik]
ich finds richtig dass eigentlichen
täter rechtliches gehör trägt und gerade
in den bereichen der zimmer genau wie
beweglichkeit
sobald wir es noch nicht ganz genau
falsch machen
und solange mir nicht irgend etwas
straffer zeit gemacht hat oder wo oder
betroffene person wo bereit ist zum
ritter können wir genau wieder in der
konflikt diene als profi gab es doch sie
finden glaube es braucht im zimmer und
sechs geschafft hat darüber sehr viel
zivilcourage und mut ein schrittmacher
im labor wo nun sicherlich wäre es
tatsächlich zu einer anzeige wegen
ehrverletzung oder wie es juristisch
heißt übler nachrede gekommen hätte der
vater versuchen müssen seinen sohn zum
reden zu bringen
das kann sie dass man eine übrigen räte
mit einem dass man über strafbare
handlung bezichtigt jetzt ist aber das
so wenn man das im guten glauben und
einem interesse vom kind macht und hat
tatsächlich lewis bestimmt dann ist das
auch kraft fertig also dann ist mir da
nicht strafbar zu einer eher verletzungs
klage kommt es nicht
heute weiß man auch warum löst das
problem auf seine art er kündigt in
solothurn nur zwei monate später und
schafft es so einmal mehr seine spuren
zu verwischen
wird frau chiemi natürlich immer zu
wenig gemacht ich bin schockiert über
das ausmaß von der täter überhaupt dass
die taten sind dass das so wie troja und
würde viel ich ne frau gewitter piratin
heute will ich haben in neuen
arbeitgeber wenig weiß dass das heimlich
sondern richtete damals informiert die
perspektive den neuen arbeitgeber nicht
und weil ich damit möglichen
juristischen problemen aus gleich wie
die arbeitgeber vor ihr
wenn ein solches anstellungsverhältnis
beendet ist ist man wohl einfach froh
ist das problem vom tisch
ja ich glaub es schon herz- und es wird
immer ein heißer hätte bliebe ich glaube
im bereitschafts akzeptiere dass die hsh
dazu gibt und wir bereit sie ist mir
herzlich gezogen ebenso trotzdem der
herr der platz lange und hätte vor allem
mit also vor ort zum anderen
bz einmal mehr weiter und arbeitet in
deutschland für die sinnstiftung die
gleiche sinnstiftung die in mir dann
2011 für meinen film über hyperaktive
kinder vermittelt es ist juni 2011 und
ich bin mitten in den dreharbeiten
meines films
plötzlich informieren nicht b und die
sinnstiftung man habe sich im
gegenseitigen einvernehmen getrennt
über die gründe habe man stillschweigen
vereinbart
das ist ein halbes jahr bevor mein film
ausgestrahlt wird und ich das mail vom
vater aus dem baselbiet erhalte darüber
was damals geschehen war redet die
sinnstiftung erst nachdem auch die
polizei an die öffentlichkeit geht
trauma experte lutz ulrich besser
arbeitet für die sinnstiftung damals
bekam er einen verdächtigen hinweis der
erste verdacht kam dadurch auf dass eine
kindertherapeuten die mich aus der
ausbildung in psychiatrie kannte eine
anfrage gestellt hat was wir machen ich
habe hier einen jungen der berichtet von
sexuellen übergriffen durch einen
pädagogen der bei der sinnstiftung
angestellt ist in diesem augenblick habe
ich die leitung sind stiftung und herrn
wieder darüber informiert dass hier
möglicherweise in ihren eigenen reihen
im rahmen der 1 projekte ein pius xii
der täter sein unwesen treiben könnte
und diese verdachtsmomente sind sehr
angenommen worden
der täter ist konfrontiert worden damit
hat dann eine typische form von
verschiedenen formen des sogenannten
grau bestehens des bagatellisieren des
verharmlosen des widersprüche aufzeigen
von sich gegeben und ist dann obwohl er
erst mal nur ein verdacht war von der
sinnstiftung aus den diensten entlassen
worden
zwei tage bevor es bevor er wieder die
leitung eines weiteren ein projekt
übernehmen sollte
b wird sofort freigestellt aber auch in
deutschland will die familie des
betroffenen jungen keine anzeige
erstatten
obwohl ihr die sinnstiftung dringend
dazu rät selbst will die sinnstiftung
über den kopf des kindes hinweg keine
polizeilichen ermittlungen einleiten
sie entscheidet auch nicht öffentlich zu
informieren um allfällig betroffene
familien nicht zu beunruhigen bevor die
polizei tätig wird einmal mehr bleibt
alles unter dem deckel
[Musik]
wir sind aber heute der meinung dass man
hier manchmal auch sozusagen ja den
schweren schritt tun muss das risiko
einzugehen eine verleumdungsklage zu
riskieren
für die man sich dann verantworten muss
wenn doch immerhin das bauchgefühl und
erste aussagen so gravierend sind wie
sich jetzt herausgestellt hat nach
seiner freistellung zieht sich b ins
berner oberland zurück und lässt sich
von einem heim anstellen
seine alphütte hat er immer noch erst
ein halbes jahr später im januar 2012
fliegt alles auf aufgrund eines weiteren
missbrauchs an einem anderen kind meldet
sich endlich eine mutter bei der polizei
seither laufen die polizeilichen
ermittlungen in deren verlauf b schritt
für schritt 21 sexuelle missbräuche an
knaben gestanden hat es wären sicher
weniger gewesen wäre es früher zu einer
anzeige gekommen
die glauben in hera locker ich glaub mir
nie in bereitschaft den hörer akzeptiere
dass es sechs stoff der begeht das cf6
dass es übergriffe situationen geht und
das mit hair alaska wo fängt ja und das
emmental kultur für achtsamkeit
entwickeln
noch ein letztes mal höre ich vom vater
aus dem baselbiet er ist erleichtert
dass dem gefängnis ist und wohl auch
dass damit endlich klar ist dass er über
all die jahre keine ungerechtfertigten
anschuldigungen gemacht hatte
zudem sagt er habe sein sohn nach der
aussage bei der polizei wieder 20 kilo
abgenommen
für das was geschehen ist wird b sich
vor gericht verantworten müssen
sein fall zeigt aber dass es bei
sexuellem missbrauch an kindern vor
allem bei institutionen eine mauer von
angst und schweigen gibt die pädophile
sexualtäter schützt und dass kinder ein
couragiertes umfeld brauchen welches
verdachtsmomente ernst nimmt solange nur
ein bruchteil dieser fälle überhaupt
bekannt wird nützen schärfere gesetze
nur wenig
[Musik]